l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
surveille de très près la pire à
l'apparition de cas humains de grippe
aviaire ont peu de temps la corée du sud
le vietnam le japon est maintenant
bangkok ont été touchés l'union
européenne a décidé de fermer ses portes
aux importations de volailles de
thaïlande
sylvain tiers bangkok a enfin reconnu
que des enfants avaient contracté la
grippe aviaire
après des semaines de dénégation nous
avons trois cas suspects deux sont
avérés un enfant de 5 ans et un autre de
deux ans le troisième ne l'est pas
pourtant il ya trois jours
le premier ministre thaïlandais invitait
les médias sa table pour déguster du
poulet aujourd'hui la priorité du
gouvernement est plus que jamais
d'empêcher la population paniquée et
dites aux gens qu'ils ne doivent pas
céder à la confusion et à la panique
d'abord ce n'est pas comme le strass
pour attraper cette maladie il faut
toucher les poulets malades la grippe
aviaire ne s'attrape pas en mangeant du
poulet mais elle a quand même tué cinq
personnes au vietnam des foyers ont été
détectés en corée du sud et au japon
de grandes campagnes d'abattage ont
commencé pour l'instant c'est le poulet
qui transmet la maladie aux hommes mais
la grande crainte des médecins c'est une
mutation du virus ont craint le plus
c'est qu'un
un virus humain classique comme on en a
eu en france cet hiver plus savoureuse
de poulet de grippe du poulet infecte
une même personne peut que de la nes à
nouveau virus
un super virus on va dire qui a à la
fois le caractère d'une nouveauté du
virus de la grippe aviaire et des
caractères d'adaptation du virus humain
le japon les philippines et l'union
européenne vont interdire les
importations de volailles de thaïlande
la crise sanitaire risque de pénaliser
lourdement les éleveurs la thaïlande est
en effet le premier exportateur de
poulet en asie